and finally new rule of all the fairy
tales we've told ourselves here at
America the one we most need to get rid
of now is in America no one is above the
law what conservatives get weepy eyed
about this magic infallible Constitution
that Jesus personally delivered to the
Capitol it's incumbent on the rest of us
to remain clear-eyed about its flaws and
when you don't have to follow the orders
of law enforcement as Trump clearly
doesn't you are above the law I am I'm
tired of hearing TV lawyers say the
president can't refuse a subpoena even
Rudy Giuliani said that he said you got
to do it I mean you don't have a choice
the exit pat was in 1998 when Clinton
was president now Rudy says we don't
have to he's the president in the United
States as Rudy's three ex-wives can tell
you he's not really good at being
married to anything
I know liberals have this vision of
Trump forced out of the White House and
arrested but that's not going to happen
no matter how many cartoons I bet you
post on your Facebook feed
the noose is tightening I hear people
say no the noose is not tightening his
face is always that color the
Constitution does not give permission to
indict or prosecute a president you
can't legally resist arrest but he can
could you ignore a subpoena could you
pardon yourself if your obedience to the
law is strictly voluntary or compelled
by shame of which he has none you are
above the law if you don't believe me
the next time a cop is writing you a
ticket
try saying I don't think so officer your
traffic stop is a witch hunt and don't
bother arresting me either I've already
pardoned myself executive privilege
[ __ ] checks and balances is a cute
theory but have you met Paul Ryan the
Constitution only has two recourses for
an evil president the 25th amendment
which allows the cabinet to remove a
president who was crazy and
incapacitated which might work if
Trump's cabinet wasn't crazy and
incapacitated
and impeachment but impeachment means
nothing without conviction which
requires 67 votes in the Senate which
even after the best blue wave election
ever would mean at least a dozen
Republicans crossing party lines not
going to happen we're on the honor
system and Republicans are fresh out of
honor
John Adams had it right back in 1780
when he said there is nothing which I
dread so much as a division of the
Republic into two great parties but
that's what happened and even the
founders couldn't foresee our current
level of tribalism where half of us
would hear Laurel and half would ariani
they never imagined a congress full of
shameless partisan enablers who wouldn't
turn on Trump if they found out he was
using the eternal flame to light farts
[Applause]
and in that atmosphere this president
doesn't have to do anything anything
except explore how far he can go until
he stopped like the way he used to walk
into the dressing room with the Miss
Universe pageant oh I know I know
we're playing 3d chess and he yeah he's
playing I tipped the board over because
here's what's gonna happen
Muller will request an interview Trump
will say no Muller will then subpoena
him Trump will say Go Fish it goes to
the Supreme Court their partisan now -
we learned that in Bush vs. gore but say
they do the right thing and order him to
honor the subpoena and he still says no
what do we do then call Dog the Bounty
Hunter
that's when the same experts will be
saying a president has never defied the
Supreme Court stop telling me he'll
never do that he always does that it's
not normal is not an argument that works
on Donald Trump that's the kind of dare
that makes him hard it's like a penis
pump that runs on coal
if the Supreme Court rules against him
he'll attack them just like he did the
FBI in the Justice Department that
Supreme Court will be the new deep state
enemy and their rulings will be food
news this year when President Xi of
China made himself president for life
Trump said President for life I think
it's great maybe we'll have to give that
a shot someday a month later he
suggested he should have four terms like
FDR people say he's joking about this
stuff but when is Trump ever told a joke
his idea of a funny gag is making Mike
Pence kiss his ass in public maybe the
reason he keeps saying he wants to be
President for life is because he wants
to be President for life